also das ist ja ein vorurteil das
schweizer nur käse von liszt und
manchmal gibt es auch recht und zog
gegen haye sie sind die erste den ich
chocri sagt das hat sich ja nicht
hinten finden es gut wenn du das ist
wirklich mag es auch hinten ein dirndl
wahl wissen sie was das holz ja weil ich
eine elfjährige tochter hat weiß ich was
das haben sie auch selber gemacht ich
bin eigentlich nur darum einen instagram
account zu promoten und da ist natürlich
die auch in extra chat und oder der alte
schmidt der alte schritt kommen wir
gerade zum thema ich weiß wer also so
oder so wir haben jetzt weiter das doch
super
ja man muss sich nicht entscheidend also
in berlin muss seine seehofer rechnet in
zukunft mit söder aber wir waren ja
schon lange mit seehofer vertreten
bisher dann ministerpräsident wurde
deswegen also schmerzgrenze ist ziemlich
gut was ich schon wir machen heute ein
käsefondue okay dass ich allen die
knoblauchzehe es auch gut wenn sie
später noch das ist super wenn auch
termine namen hören wo ich jetzt nicht
stinken wollte aber nicht stinken die
frau ist auch eine arbeitende frau wie
ist es aus ihrem sprüche kalender 20 17
nee nee so viele teile hat das ja auch
nicht wie ich das machen wir einfach
viele instagram channel und listen also
es dorothea ich habe ja ja ja ja wenn
meine internationalen fans und fragen
was wollen sie in schnaps wasser wasser
sowohl auf ihren geburtstag
dann haben sie geburtstag 19 echt krass
der selbst einen tag vom 26
kommen sie mit glyphosat was ist das
design unkraut mit lassen sie mit
unglaublich aber christian schmidt doch
das jetzt sagen zu durchgewunken hat
mich nicht was hat er gemacht
er hat für eine 5-jahres verlängerung
gestimmt für glyphosat können welche
bundestagsabgeordneten sie die sexieste
ich mir noch keine gedanken
bürgerrechten gibt es gar keine nehmen
sie mal so einen kleinen klaps auf nero
geben will
das ist jetzt keine fantasie von mir ich
hab sie auch eine google da gibt es so
ein foto wo sie sich aus einem pool raus
so lettern
so gibt es das ich bin
rettungsschwimmerin ja aber das war
nicht so eine traurige nachricht wird
ehrlicherweise tatsächlich
rettungsschwimmerinnen und bin total
sie machen nein ich bin absolut dafür
dass man sie retten
deswegen mache ich natürlich muss geht
auch immer interviews zum thema
schwimmen
was war ihr lieblingsfach in der schule
es ist stimmt leider wirklich weil sie
war in sozialkunde was möglich ist
völlig normal was jetzt irgendwie können
sie dateien ich kann doch das vaterunser
auf mitteilen
und das kann ich nicht mal auf das
kannst du doch irgendwann ist das thema
auch ja ja ich würde mit angela merkel
was backen nicht rasch genug dass man
drauf okay ich kann ihnen versprechen
dass ich das nicht hinkriegen werde für
sie ja das würde ich jetzt auch echt
wundern sie sich wenn sie nicht mal ihre
csu sachen durchbringen können nicht nur
angela merkel
ich würde sogar wenn ich durchsetzen
könnte nicht probieren für sowieso nicht
was jetzt werden sie so schreibt
[Gelächter]
innenstadt furchtbar aus sie wollen
jetzt an zu streiten aber ich dachte
auch gerade was haben sie da so viel
flüssigkeit
ja ich habe ihnen sind ja nur klumpen
bis heute also eine krater am mond
gleich
weißt du was wird also wissen sie was
passieren wird nach ausstrahlung dieser
sendung war es dass die erde
staatsbürgerschaft aberkannt bekommen
aber ich habe auch noch normal gemessen
deswegen habe ich gedacht kann ich das
nicht so treffen aber ob der tross
hereinlässt natürlich der rub mich an
und
die sache gegessen jetzt sind wir fast
schon so weit dass wir die stärke mit
kirschwasser hinzufügen könnte das war
sehr großzügig perfekt
jetzt tippen wir doch mal wollen sich
brot oder ich hab auch aus balge schluss
dabei weiß münster nehmen
das passt ja gar nicht dazu das ist
jetzt wieder diese angst vor der
vermischung verschiedener für den extra
kick können sie auch wie bisher und
sagen sie gehen will findet schokoladen
fondue am besten aber es gibt auch noch
der schokolade von lysistrate im käse
es ist total eklig was ist meine kultur
also ich kann es irgendwie alles
professioneller ich glaube ich habe so
einen schweizer gene in habe sie sind
einfach besser als ich okay es war
immerhin in ihrem alter der bundestag
wieder warum bin ich selbstständig bald
nix kannten ja ich habe ein wie viele
follower haben sie mal ins tor
7000 wachsen nur 7000 und was machen sie
im internet sind und ich leide sie sich
wein und ich mache ja aber auf twitter
über 67.000 ist es auch und facebook
habe ich zwei accounts bei den privaten
ist ja bei 5.000 schluss ja gut 5000
freunde aber unter anderen sind sie
keine ahnung 13 oder so
13.000 mehr als 100000 mir ist das gut
für mich für sie nicht ich sage mal ganz
offen wenn es das schon alles wieder
gegeben hätte hätte ich jetzt auch mehr
dann haben sie halt die gnade der späten
geburt ich habe in jeder hinsicht
niederländischen bergen joghurt so kopp
deshalb ist es wichtig
[Musik]